es ist ein schockierender fund in berlin
in der rummelsburger bucht auf einer
grünfläche wo die leiche eines erst 15
jahre alten mädchens entdeckt der täter
hat sich mittlerweile der polizei
gestellt weitere details zu ihm kennt
mein kollege til biermann erst jetzt an
der fundstelle für was genau wissen wir
bisher über den täter der täter ist 41
jahre alt ist einschlägig vorbestraft
wegen sexualdelikten saß deswegen auch
schon in der psychiatrie
er ist deutscher wie die polizei
mitteilte ohne migrationshintergrund
das opfer das 15 jährige mädchen stammt
hier aus dagegen da hat ist eine
deutsche mit migrationshintergrund wie
die polizei mitteilte und am mittwoch
stellte sich der mutmaßliche täter mit
seinem anwalt der polizei und führte die
beamten zur fundstelle mittwoch rund 30
wurde das mädchen hier genau hinter mir
gefunden das ist ein trostloser ort hier
ein ehemaliger fußball gran platz wo
sich jetzt schon ein paar pflanzen durch
den grand gebohrt haben dort hatte er
das mädchen abgelegt das tote wie es
dorthin gelangte ob es hier starb oder
ob es hier hin trug ist noch nicht klar
klar ist dass es ein trostloser ort hier
ist ich drehe man die kamera um im
moment sorry dass die rummelsburger
bucht hier sollte eigentlich schon seit
längerem ein luxusprojekt stehen ein
aquarien welt luxus türme sie wurden
jedoch von anwohner zunächst verhindert
es gab 35.000 unterschriften gesammelt
wurden hier ist jetzt einen obdachlosen
camp eine zeltstadt und auch auf dem
wasser haben sich hausboote
zusammengeschlossen zu einer art
waterworld allerdings stammt der täter
nicht aus dieser obdachlosenszene aber
es ist klar
nachts ist es hier dunkel verlassen und
hier musste das mädchen offen mal
sterben wie die staatsanwaltschaft
mitteilte aus verdeckungsabsicht der
mann hatte offenbar versucht das mädchen
zu vergewaltigen und hat es dann
ermordet aus angst gefasst zu werden
aber letztendlich stellte er sich der
polizei